ya que hemos visto en algún vídeo
anterior que los enantiómero son estéreo
isómeros que son reflejos no
superponibles uno del otro entonces
digamos si queremos dibujar el
enantiómero de este compuesto una manera
de hacerlo sería reflejar este compuesto
en el espejo y si tú observas este
esqueleto de carbono con el grupo h
dirigido hacia nosotros en el espacio
eso sería este modelo de la izquierda
aquí está nuestro esqueleto de carbono
con el grupo h orientado hacia nosotros
en el espacio si reflejamos este
compuesto en el espejo veremos al
enantiómero en el espejo reflejado la
imagen del espejo en la derecha no es
súper ponible con respecto a nuestro
modelo de la izquierda entonces
dibujamos lo que vemos vemos nuestro
esqueleto de carbono así
entonces lo dibujamos este es el
esqueleto de carbono y el grupo h se
dirige hacia nosotros en el espacio lo
podemos representar entonces con una
cuña y la voy a llenar de color y pongo
o h entonces este dibujo en la derecha
es el enantiómero al dibujo de la
izquierda ahora hay otra manera de
representar al enantiómero de la derecha
y para hacer eso veamos un vídeo en este
vídeo podemos imaginar un eje que
atraviesa este carbono y luego rota
alrededor de este eje para darnos otro
punto de vista del enantiómero este es
el modelo del enantiómero y puedes ver
que el esqueleto de carbono con el lo h
que sale nuestra dirección y está pegado
a este carbono y el hidrógeno en la
dirección opuesta a nosotros imaginamos
rotar alrededor de un eje a través de
este carbono así que hacemos eso rotamos
y entonces vemos otra manera de ver al
enantiómero ahora vemos que el esqueleto
de carbono
se mira así y en lo h sal en la
dirección opuesta de nosotros y el
hidrógeno sale hacia nosotros entonces
aquí tenemos algunas fotos del vídeo
para ayudarnos con los dibujos y podemos
ver que que esta foto es justo este
compuesto aquí está el esqueleto de
carbono y puedes ver a lo h
dirigiéndose hacia nosotros en el
espacio entonces en el vídeo tomamos
este compuesto y lo rotamos para que nos
diera esta imagen de la derecha
estas son dos imágenes del mismo
compuesto y esto nos da otra manera de
dibujar nuestro compuesto esta vez
nuestro esqueleto de carbono se mira a
sí voy a dibujar el esqueleto de carbono
y bueno el grupo h se aleja de nosotros
en el espacio entonces voy a dibujar al
grupo h con rayas estos dos dibujos
representan al mismo compuesto
representan adelante homero que
queríamos dibujar y bueno hay dos
maneras de de dibujar el antiguo - la
primera es reflejando el compuesto en el
espejo y eso por lo que hicimos primero
tomamos este compuesto y lo reflejamos
en el espejo luego dibujamos lo que
vimos y eso nos dio este dibujo del
enantiómero y vimos que este dibujo en
la derecha es lo mismo que este dibujo
de la izquierda ahora note la diferencia
entre este dibujo y nuestro compuesto
original los esqueletos de carbono son
los mismos si miras bien baja observa
estos dos la única diferencia es que
cambiamos la cuña por rayas y esa es
otra manera conveniente de dibujar
pero si inicias con una cuña lo cambias
por unas rayas y si inicias con rayas lo
cambias por una cuña ahora dibujemos el
enantiómero de este compuesto el primer
método que utilizaremos es el método de
espejo entonces bueno aquí está aquí es
una representación simplificada de
nuestro compuesto y estamos ignorando
cosas como las conformaciones del anillo
en este carbono nuestro bromo va hacia
abajo en el espacio aquí está este
carbono y puedes ver que el bromo baja y
en este carbono el bromo va hacia arriba
en el espacio en el espejo puedes ver la
imagen reflejada o el enantiómero así
que dibujamos al enantiómero aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo ciclohexano y en
este carbono tenemos al bromo que va
hacia abajo en el espacio
entonces dibujo al bromo yendo hacia
abajo y en este carbono tenemos el bromo
que va hacia arriba en el espacio así
que lo pongo con una cuña
lleno a esta cuña de color aquí tenemos
al bromo así que esto de la derecha es
el enantiómero y bueno en ocasiones
puedes no tener un juego de modelo o un
espejo pero puedes dibujar la imagen del
espejo simplemente usando esta imagen de
la derecha puedes imaginar un espejo
aquí y justo como ves aquí este bromo
está reflejado en el espejo este bromo
también está reflejado en el espejo
entonces estos bromo se refleja en el
uno con el otro y este carbono es
opuesto a este carbono entonces son este
carbono y este y este carbono es opuesto
a este carbono entonces son este carbono
y este son algunos trucos que te pueden
ayudar a dibujar la imagen del espejo
ahora hay otra manera de representar al
enantiómero de la derecha y para esto
veamos un vídeo aquí tenemos imágenes
reflejadas de nuestros enantiómero y si
rotamos al enantiómero de la derecha
tendremos otro punto de vista ambos
centros de calidad fueron invertidos
como puedes ver
y sólo para probar que son en anti o
meros intentamos superponer uno en el
otro
nota que no podemos hacerlo por lo tanto
estas son imágenes reflejadas en un
espejo que no son superponibles entonces
esta imagen en la derecha del vídeo
nuestra relación entre los dos
enantiómero se piensa que estamos
reflejando en un espejo a la molécula de
la izquierda y así es como podemos ver
adelante hombro de la izquierda pero
tomamos este enantiómero de la izquierda
y lo rote para obtener esta posición
entonces dibujamos el enantiómero desde
esta perspectiva iniciamos con nuestro
anillo ciclohexano y puedes ver en este
carbono nuestro bromo va hacia abajo en
el espacio así que dibujo rayas y pongo
bromo y en este carbono el bromo va
hacia arriba en el espacio así que viene
hacia nosotros entonces dibujo una cuña
la llenó de color y pongo bromo esta es
otra manera de representar enantiómero
este dibujo y este dibujo
dos maneras de representar la misma
molécula este es el enantiómero al
compuesto de la izquierda entonces
veamos el compuesto original y
comparemos este dibujo con el de la
derecha note que en este carbono el
bromo se dirige hacia ti en el espacio
mientras que en este carbono el bromo se
aleja detiene el espacio y en este
carbono el bromo se aleja de ti mientras
que en este carbono el bromo viene hacia
tiene el espacio entonces para dibujar
enantiómero simplemente invertimos todos
los centros de quiralidad si tienes una
cuña lo cambias por guiones y si tienes
guiones lo cambias por una cuña entonces
esta manera resulta a veces más fácil
simplemente asegúrate de invertir todos
los centros de finalidad para dibujar el
enantiómero para compuestos bi cíclicos
es más conveniente usar el método de
espejo si queremos dibujar el
enantiómero de este compuesto podemos
imaginar un un espejo aquí y podemos
usar esta imagen de arriba como guía
entonces puedes ver que él
está reflejado en el espejo y el cloro
también está reflejado en el espejo
así que dibujamos voy a dibujar el
hidrógeno y el enlace yendo hacia abajo
hacia este carbono y el cloro yendo
hacia abajo desde aquí entonces nota
cómo este hidrógeno está reflejado y
este cloro también está reflejado
siguiente paso pensemos en reflejar a
este carbono entonces tenemos que
dibujar una línea en esta dirección así
que este carbono está reflejado con este
y voy a voy a extender esta línea una
línea horizontal
entonces estos carbonos son son este y
este están reflejados en nuestro espejo
y siguiente paso dibujamos una línea
hacia arriba
hacia arriba en el espacio relativo a
esta línea horizontal y eso nos lleva a
este carbono estamos reflejando a este
carbono nuestro espejo ahora vamos con
este carbono el cual sube en el espacio
entonces dibujo una línea horizontal
aquí para facilitar para facilitar
nuestro dibujo queremos subir en el
espacio desde este carbono entonces subo
es este enlace así que este carbono está
reflejando a este carbono y ahora
reflejamos el carbono que está aquí
arriba dibujo una línea horizontal
entonces puedes pensar en este carbono
de arriba reflejando a este carbono
dibujamos las líneas sube desde este
carbono y baja hacia este carbono es más
como un ejercicio de dibujo luego vamos
a bajar un poco y dejaremos esta línea
con un hueco para representar que está
yendo por atrás y es el enlace a este
carbono de atrás luego desde este
carbono dibujamos una línea hacia abajo
para enlazarlo con el carbono de atrás y
conectamos a estos dos carbonos y
finalmente dibujamos nuestro enantiómero
el de la derecha es el enantiómero del
compuesto de la izquierda y solo para
probar que esto de la derecha es el
enantiómero veremos un vídeo donde
intentó superponer la imagen del espejo
en el compuesto original aquí tenemos
dos enantiómero son imágenes reflejadas
en un espejo que no son superponibles y
para probar que no son super imposibles
voy a rotar el de la derecha y al tratar
de sobreponer lo en el de la izquierda
tú puedes ver que no encajan por lo
tanto son enantiómero